new year new weapons new armor new zones
new skills the new Guild Wars 2 living
world season 4 episode 5 has a lot of
new in it if you were new there's a ton
to do and if you've been here while
there's still a ton to do also if you've
been here a really long time there's
stuff you may remember from the first
guild wars but we'll get into that later
now let's get to know the latest Guild
Wars Episode all or nothing there's
10,000 years of history in the Guild
Wars world but that doesn't mean you
need to start reading in your downtime
the lore is there for your discovery if
you want it but Guild Wars is great even
with a cursory understanding of the hows
and whys here's a quick history lesson
if you're just jumping in or a refresher
if you're a veteran a giant dragon whose
breath turns everything it touches into
crystal named growl Katara has been a
force interior for thousands of years
he's a really bad dude he's as tall as a
skyscraper can turn himself into a storm
shoot lightning and bring down meteors
all this in addition to just being able
to smack you with part of his giant
crystal body oh and sometimes he sleeps
for 10,000 years but when he wakes up
it's time to eat magic and basically
make everything bad for most living
things the only known way of defeating
him is to use the power of another
dragon to exploit the resonance of his
crystalline bloodline basically he's
vulnerable to his family just like all
of us I happen to have a major debuff
when my mother-in-law yells
in past episodes Krakatoa gained the
ability to travel between worlds in a
realm called the mists a magical proto
reality that connects all time and space
elder dragons like crown totora eat
everything and are never satisfied
magic souls and your screen space you'll
see what I mean is huge if the creature
that eats magic and never gets full has
the ability to go to a place that one
binds the universe together and two is
made out of food for the
previously-mentioned insatiable monster
you can see why stopping him is a
priority in this episode you the
commander are teaming up with Orion a
young dragon who is the last known
relation of Calca toric to take him on
in a massive dragon fight along with a
huge cast of allies who happen to be
voiced by fantastic actors a plan is set
into motion to attack Krakatoa cand use
the innate abilities that are present in
the cute little dragon to attempt to
destroy ancient purple evil that has
scarred the land for thousands of years
good freakin water
[Music]
every living world episode as new
content updates in the form of things
like armor weapons zones instances which
in Guild Wars 2 are called fractals and
even things that modify older fractals
to make content fresh no matter how many
times you run them in all or nothing the
diviner set which is obtained by
participating in world versus world
combat but kind Guild Wars 2 is known
for us being introduced to PvE as far as
new weapons in this episode there's a
legendary longbow called ferrous being
added that players have been waiting to
see for a long time the bow itself
changes from a solid to pure light while
in use adding lightning and a glow aura
around you making you look like
whichever Greek god had a lightning bow
another weapon addition is a new
upgradable set called Dragon's Blood in
the course of the episode you an arene
or task to create a new Dragon's Blood
weapon to use against Krakatoa
the ordeal involves channeling powerful
magical energies fighting corruption in
oneself and weirdly enough listening to
your mother
it's all very deep and moving but at the
end of it you can get a kick-ass looking
weapon the new fractal called sirens
wreath is basically everything I liked
as a kid in one instance well everything
except pizza you get to fight pirates
look for buried treasure and also there
are dinosaurs and ghosts I feel like all
these things should have been put
together before now but Guild Wars 2 did
it so at least now it exists a ghost
pirate captain is luring ships with the
promise of treasure but when they get
close illusion magic causes them to
wreck and the captain then adds their
valuables to the ghost pirate horde for
even more boring power you and your crew
go to try to break the curse and an
awesome good time but sadly no pizza
unless you order it I mentioned you
veteran players earlier and that's
because in this episode you'll be
returning to Thunderhead Peaks the zone
that should be familiar from the
original guild war
this game takes care of its elder
dragons last but definitely not least
there's a new skill mastery for your
mounts the mountain Guild Wars to change
how you see the world of the game as
each mount has different abilities and
ways to maneuver through teria the new
skill is called bond of fate it allows
you to jump off the back of your mount
and launch yourself into a higher jump
Glide or even transition onto a Griffon
mount using a previous skill mastery
called soaring rescue each living world
episode changes Guild Wars 2 so it truly
stays alive both in the feel of the
world itself and in the Guild Wars 2
community which is very active and one
of the most welcoming groups I've
encountered online big shout out to my
guild VIP and I'll see you in world V
world